let's start today with a sort of thick
and Meaty policy segment and let's talk
about social security and the context of
this and it's been much requested by
many of you is the absolute apoplexy
from Republicans that the mere
suggestion that over the last few years
they've hinted at and even sometimes
overtly said maybe we should cut Social
Security maybe the cuts would be lower
benefits maybe the cuts would be you
have to work longer meaning raise the
retirement age or whatever the case may
be but when Joe Biden said at his State
of the Union Address a couple of weeks
ago some of these Republicans want to
cut Social Security they went crazy and
started saying Joe Biden is a liar and
we would never do that and on and on and
on and then yesterday on CNBC
incomes former vice president Mike Pence
and he says oh we should definitely put
on the table that we might cut Social
Security and Medicare they've spent
weeks saying we would never do that stop
accusing us of maybe wanting to be open
to considering the possibility
of ever cutting Social Security and
Medicare and then here's Mike Pence
saying oh yeah yeah no like we should
definitely think of that because of the
debt is that well I I respect uh the
speaker's commitment to take Social
Security and Medicare off the table for
the debt ceiling negotiations
we've got to put them on the table in
the long term and right now President
Biden's policy is insolvency I mean
we're we're looking at a debt crisis in
this country over the next 25 years that
is by entitlements and nobody in
Washington D.C wants to talk about it
I've been going around the country I'm
going to continue to try and do my part
yeah
what a heroic thing he's doing what'd
you do about in tons well I think first
and foremost you have to explain to
people what's going on we got a 32
trillion dollar national debt right now
Andrew
having a national debt the same size as
our nation's economy is unsustainable
last time that happened was right after
well I don't disagree with you I'm just
curious what's on the for you on
entitlements what's on the table well I
I think it begins with education it
begins with having the American people
understand yeah so twice like what
exactly would you do well we got to tell
people all about it remember what
happened at the State of the Union Union
when Joe Biden merely suggested some
Republicans
are open to cutting take the economy
hostage I get it unless I agree to the
economic plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are yeah
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share of some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
no
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you a copy
I'll give you a copy of the proposal and
there with you some Marjorie Trader
green standing and screaming so they say
for weeks and weeks no we would never
ever ever ever ever do that and then
here goes Mike Pence and he's like oh
yeah it should absolutely be on the
table we have way too much debt so let's
talk about the truth on this talking
point so that we can all understand what
is going on because the right says
Social Security is insolvent it just
doesn't work financially it doesn't work
here's the truth and the truth is it's
it's a good thing and a bad thing that
it's really clear what's going on
because sometimes when things are so
clear and simple the right loves to
pretend like they're really complicated
despite Republicans claiming Social
Security is insolvent meaning unable to
pay the benefits that it owes or will
owe people if we do nothing we change
nothing at all about social security
there is enough money to pay full
benefits until 2035 that means like if
you keep doing just the inflation
adjustments for cost of living to what
people get you change nothing about what
people in other than continuing to do
the inflation adjustment to the Social
Security Catholic literally nothing
changes until 2040 2035 there is no
problem and if we continue with the do
nothing scenario starting in 2035 you
can reduce benefits to 80 of what they
would be inflation adjusted and then it
still continues to be fine making no
changes whatsoever other than moving
benefits from 100 to 80 percent
now what is the reason that this is
going on why is this even a conversation
changing demographics more and more
people are retiring relative to the
number of workers so as Baby Boomers
continue to retire the number of people
receiving benefits relative to the
number of people paying in is going to
fall uh out of balance towards the
retirees and then secondly people on
average are living longer meaning that
the estimates for how long people are
going to be receiving benefits it's more
years because people are living longer
okay now I think it's unacceptable
to go down to 80 of benefits but again
with doing nothing
fine until 2035 and then fine for a very
long time on 80 of benefits I believe if
you've paid in based on getting a
hundred percent of benefits you should
get them okay but I've laid out the
do-nothing scenario it's not exactly
insolvent is it it's everything's fine
for 11 12 years and then we do a 20
reduction but let's fix it okay how do
we fix it there's quite a few ways
they're relatively simple it's just a
matter of finding the political will to
do it as a reminder right now in 2023
Social Security contributions are made
on your first hundred and sixty thousand
dollars that you earn per year okay once
you get Beyond 160 you stop paying into
Social Security the amount that is paid
in is 12.4 percent now many of you might
say David it I'm only paying 6.2 percent
the reason is that in a normal job if
you're a W-2 employee that uh 12.4
percent is divided between you and your
employer so instead of you paying 12.4
percent you pay 6.2 your employer pays
6.2 if you're self-employed like me you
pay the full 12.4 okay so what can you
do one thing you can do is you can
increase that rate you could say instead
of 12.4 percent it's going to be
something higher on that first hundred
and sixty thousand dollars I don't like
that idea because it disproportionately
hits those earning under a hundred and
sixty thousand but you could do do that
you could say instead of 12.4 percent
we're going to pay 15 and that's going
to stretch out how long we can pay a
hundred percent of benefits second
option you can raise the cap so you keep
it at 12.4 percent
but instead of paying that on your first
hundred and sixty thousand that you make
maybe you paid on your first 180 or
maybe on your first 200. that seems like
a better option to me number three you
could raise the retirement age it's very
controversial I don't like it but you
could say well you've got to wait longer
before you can get benefits what I do
like is giving a bonus if you delay
retirement by choice this is already
part of the way it works and for people
for whom this is new I think it's useful
to know this stuff right now you can
start receiving reduced benefits at age
62. the standard age to get benefits is
67. so your 100 benefit would be if you
say at 67 years of age I want to start
getting the benefits from 62 to 67 you
get less and if you at age 67 say I
don't need the money yet either because
I have private retirement or I'm going
to continue working or whatever if you
say I'm going to wait until I'm 68 or 69
or 70 you get even more benefits when
you do retire we could expand that and
say hey you know what people are living
longer and many people would gladly
delay getting their social security
benefits you could say if you choose to
wait until age 71 or 72 or 73 or 74 you
get more benefits which leaves money in
the trust fund than a kind of crew
earnings and gains you don't force
anybody to do anything but you give an
option that's interesting a fourth
option is to move the money in the
Social Security trust fund to something
with potentially higher return but with
more risk right now Social Security
invests in low-risk government bonds
very safe very low return without going
into we're going to buy Bitcoin you
could slightly expand the list of
investment vehicles that social
securities trust fund can be invested in
with the idea that there will be a
little more uh volatility but over time
you should get a higher return and that
could close that Gap that will
eventually appear and then lastly you
could also increase immigration bring in
people to work to pay into the system in
order to even out that ratio so we can
fix this with some tweaks you could
raise the cap a little bit and then you
could offer greater benefits to people
who choose to delay retirement a little
more
increase immigration a little bit to
increase the number of people paying in
and consider slightly higher yield but
slightly higher risk Investments with
some of the money it's not brain surgery
but it's a political gridlock and we
have the solutions if only we could get
our elected officials to put them in
place
lastly mixing this specific issue of the
Social Security trust fund generally
with that of the national debt is also
very dishonest because the truth is
social security is its own trust fund
and we can manage and make tweaks to
that individually the conversation about
the debt is fine but it really is a
separate conversation so after weeks of
saying we would never do that Mike Pence
shows up and says oh yeah yeah we should
definitely consider that
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below